joining us now on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line
is bill auram uh from the athletic
um lakers writer and more importantly a
university of montana grizzly bill
what's going on
how much ryan how you doing man i'm
doing good tell us a little bit a little
bit about your uh about your grizz days
i mean like
i mean i mean how much time you got
talking about like you know hanging out
in missoula
subzero weather going to grizz games
uh you know the
the best football program in the country
that nobody that that nobody outside of
montana knows about greatest rivalry in
the country with montana state something
you know a little bit about oh yeah um
so i you know i love i love it very much
and uh it's still home for
me where how did you how did you get to
montana how did you get to the
university i mean how did that come
about where are you from originally
so i grew up in oregon ryan and uh and
wanted to go to a great journalism
program and want to do i want to be a
sports writer and you know you start
looking kind of around the west and and
montana jumps out i mean the university
of montana school of journalism is you
know in my mind second to none um this
is this is a recruiting pitch by the way
for everyone listening and um it was you
know it was the perfect place for me an
opportunity to work for the student
newspaper cover the grizz uh really at
you know some for some at some a high
point in their history and
uh you know just great great experience
and i wouldn't have gone anywhere else
even if i although i will tell you ryan
i i the first time i came as a as a
writer to cover a game at usc and then
later ucla i was like why didn't anybody
tell me these places existed because if
i'd known that you could go to college
in places like usc and ucla uh the
university of montana might have had
some competition oh yeah i i felt the
same way i declined uh recruiting trips
to uh eugene and to westwood for ucla
and uh i i did
i ultimately didn't regret it but when i
was on campus when we weren't playing as
well in either one of those places i
went you know what i i i may have made a
terrible mistake you know we'll see but
are you are we gonna start talking about
like the the um the cmr and capital
rivalry too
well if we want to go we had we had a
caller actually two days ago call me who
played against me in the in my junior
and senior years in the the semifinals
and state championship games and
uh it was it was reminiscent enough for
for our listeners out there who are
listening i want to get into
uh your specialty right the the los
angeles lakers last night just an
absolute embarrassment uh versus their
rival right their little brother
essentially um without kawhi and did
paul george play either right you know
neither one of them played and they just
they looked outclassed what what what's
going on there and and where do we go
from here
well listen i you know the lakers can
say that they view themselves as still
you know having a chance at this you
know mathematically they're in they're
in the play in for now um
but to me that looks like a team that is
completely let's completely let go of
the rope you know they can summon these
spurts of energy um they had a 14-0 run
at the end of the second quarter to get
within three at halftime and then
promptly got outscored 26-2 at the start
of the second half they can't defend
anybody they don't have consistent
enough offense and lebron i mean lebron
is putting up numbers man and he looks
you know he looks the part but at this
point you got to think lebron is sort of
just kind of eyeing kareem's record and
trying to basically you know bank points
while he can because i don't think
anybody has any belief that this lakers
team is is going to be able to make
noise if they even make the play in so i
view this as a team that is is
completely fractured and knows knows
their fate i mean you won't say they've
given up necessarily but i think that
this has this is going downhill fast
they've lost four in a row
i just have a hard time seeing them
really gaining any momentum anthony
davis is out for weeks still and listen
they didn't just lose to a clipper scene
without kawhi or paul george they also
don't have norman powell
so they're three are arguably their
three best players although reggie
jackson makes a case for that they're
all out you know the clippers are
playing a bunch of guys who
you know
they're young guys they're scrappy you
know they care
and they want to beat the lakers they
take pride in that in that matchup and
you know the lakers have lost seven
straight to the clippers going back to
last year i just don't see a team that
has any spirit or fight and i don't know
that they even really want to be in the
play-in because i mean listen if they if
they miss the play-in and they say
listen we were just banged up all year
we had injuries we just never got a
chance lebron a.d and russ only played
18 games together that kind of that kind
of
passes the smell test better than hey we
finally got healthy for the play-in and
then we went and got smacked by new
orleans in the first game and our season
it was over so i don't even know if they
want to be in the play-in at this point
speaking with bill orem from the
athletic lakers beat writer
how foreign is it to lebron you cover
him to see this because he's always been
the type of guy and maybe you know
father time has finally taken its toll
um even though he's having an amazing
numbers year but everywhere he went no
matter what
he was able to regardless of talent on
the basketball team find ways to make
this team competitive make his team
competitive make them winners and this
year
for whatever reason
how foreign is it to him to see this
play out the way it is
well i mean it's it's unprecedented and
i tried to ask him something about that
last night kind of the idea that he's
playing at such a high level he's
scoring at a pretty remarkable pace i
think this is the most he's scored in a
season since the year before the
decision when he went to miami um
but like
the thing that you have to understand
they're not just you know not winning at
a high level i mean this is like you
call it an embarrassment they are
getting blown out night after night by
teams that you know really have no
business blowing them out this is not
like a month ago when they got blown out
by milwaukee and lebron you know said
kind of famously you know we're not on
their level this was you know a clippers
team that more or less should be on
their level their eighth and ninth in
the west they're kind of in the same
zone potentially a play-in opponent you
know they're in the same tier of the
west and the lakers were just roundly
outclassed and and lebron said last
night they're the better team
like we're at a point where lebron can
just flatly emotionlessly
uncontroversially declare the team that
is one spot ahead of them in the
standings as the better team and nobody
even flinches at this point and so you
know
how foreign is it to lebron i mean he's
never been here but i also think like
you know you look at some of the teams
that he carried into the playoffs
he didn't have to really accommodate
someone like russell westbrook there is
right now this really bad fit with
russell westbrook where you've got a guy
who needs the ball to be effective but
when he has the ball he
is hurting the team because the ball is
inherently not in lebron james's hands
um you know russ's turnovers are way
down which i actually view as more of an
indictment of the way he's playing as
opposed to a positive because that means
he's not being himself
um last night was actually one of his
better games and he still was um
you know not a particularly productive
uh presence terrible defensively and and
so but lebron has to sort of
try to accommodate russell westbrook
because he's the highest paid player on
the team he's the starting point guard
and i actually asked frank last night
frank vogel if you know because
russ did this thing that he has done
where he where he um lamented that his
role changes every single night and
that's something that's been true of
almost everyone on this team because of
the injuries and the fact they've
started 31 different lineups in 62 games
but you know russ you know
russ made it about how
his role has changed every single night
and i asked frank about that he said
well we coached the whole team you know
blah blah blah and i so then i said well
look have you considered you know this
is something gets talked about like is
bringing russ off the bench a
possibility and i think it's telling
that he did not dismiss it he didn't say
yes but he said he said um we've talked
about everything and the fact that
you've got a guy making 45 million
dollars and and the possibility of
benching him is in play or at the very
least has like
you know been part of your coaches
meetings really tells you about what a
problem uh the russell westbrook
acquisition has been and not just for
the coaching staff but i think for
lebron james as well so it's
unprecedented for lebron to be in this
situation but he has a you know he has a
a co-star or a partner out there
that
is is is dragging the team down
cement shoes
45 million dollars i just i stopped
listening after you said that because uh
i want that gig i want that gig if i can
get it um
you know i guess the the best thing for
the lakers that's coming up here uh is
is some nostalgia right with the with
the new show winning time about the
showtime team back in the 80s bill ryan
or
uh
coach riley i mean that that sounds like
the most positive thing moving forward
because i was thinking about
the ad situation right the ad trade
ultimately and what it's cost the lakers
for their future right because they're
they're their draft picks are just
absolutely um just non-existent new
orleans has got those for the next what
foreseeable future
uh now the question to you is
is genie bus and everybody uh
surrounding the the los angeles lakers
organization are they going to look at
as that at that trade and see the swap
for the bubble championship as
as enough when this is all said and done
yeah it's a really interesting
philosophical question uh did you
philosophy major at washington state um
i
i
listen i think that they will look at it
enough because you and enough is
probably the wrong word but it was a
justified trade the the the result of
the championship justified going all in
like you saw it you saw that a.d and
lebron could win a championship together
um they have the hardware to prove it
but
it's not but i think it is a
disappointment if the lebron and anthony
davis pairing ultimately ends you know
whether it's you know a year from now
two years from now uh if it ends with
one championship and really one
legitimate shot at the championship
because you know otherwise you know
since since ads gotten here last year
they lose in the first round because of
injuries this year
i mean the first round looks almost out
of reach at this point um you know 20
games left so who knows but i mean that
seems that seems like a little
fantastical um i think you make that
trade again because it got it put you in
position to have two superstars and to
make the most of lebron's um
of lebron's uh you know kind of final
chapter you know it's everything else
that i think is a disaster it's you know
it's it's the constant changing
of the of the rest of the of the roster
it's not valuing guys you've developed
enough it's you know treating guys like
contavious caldwell pope and kyle kuzma
as throw-ins it's seeing alex caruso as
a replacement level player and letting
him walk over a few million dollars and
signing kendrick nunn who ends up not
being able to play um there's just been
kind of you know some of it i think has
been on the front office some of it's
been bad luck in terms of injuries but
it's one thing after another um you know
you make the trade again you know ten
times out of ten but the fact that
anthony davis is now you know hurt for
the second time in the first two years
of a five-year max extension you don't
feel great about that and you can't
trade him because you know you're not
going to get the
return on the dollar that you sent out
for him or
of what his real value is when he's
healthy so
um you know this is this is the lakers
core you know going forward it's lebron
james it's anthony davis and it's
you know it's probably whatever you can
get back for russell westbrook because i
don't see him coming back i mean this is
this is a real look in the mirror moment
for the lakers for an office and and and
you know everybody who influences you
know ron palinka it's you know rich paul
and lebron james it's genie bus it's
kurt and linda rambis it's you know it's
magic johnson who genie bus still called
and leans on from time to time so um you
know yes
this is about as bad as you could
imagine of ever getting in fact i would
say it's worse than you could have ever
imagined but um you know it's going to
be back to the drawing board for them
and and your point about the hbo show
i'm excited for it i think it's going to
be great it's going to be great i think
it's going to be great for the franchise
but you know the lakers also like you
know there was a story in the hollywood
reporter in which the lakers you know
that have like a lot of trepidation
about the way they're going to be
portrayed and listen like they should
hope that people are watching the hbo
show instead of watching instead of
watching their games so they can like
actually be seeing winning time because
if they tune in you know when the lakers
are playing at crypto.com arena or on
the road all they're going to see right
now is losing time yeah it's it's been
it's been tough kevin durant made
made his return last night they got beat
miami heat uh found a way to to they
really could have had a heck of a road
trip if they didn't find a way to lose
that game against the bucks the other
night but out on the west you know on
the west side of things the mavericks uh
you know beat the warriors warriors
continue to kind of stumble down the
stretch where where do you see the west
um playing out phoenix clearly at the
top is is are the warriors in trouble or
is this just something that that's
getting into the end of the race i think
it's a little bit more of that you know
the west is sort of you know kind of
getting you know more and more uh
entrenched in terms of you know who's
who
in in in the actual uh you know in the
actual race i think it's the suns i
think it's the warriors i think the
grizzlies are you know
they're such a fun story and i think
they're they're on pace to become a
contender i don't know if it's this year
but they've been fantastic um you know
dallas though like you said like you
know has been one of the hottest teams
in the league and they seem to have
really figured something out since the
trade deadline so um i actually kind of
put dallas up there in the you know in
the actual contender
here even though they might be a little
farther down in the standings and you
know i would also say i mean like i'm
still intrigued by denver right so
denver has the reigning mvp they're
going to get michael porter jr and jamal
murray back i mean that's a big ask of
both those guys to come in and
contribute
at a really high level after the
injuries they've sustained but if they
can come back and be something close to
themselves i mean how would you not look
at denver as a contender um so the west
i i think you know i i give the nod to
phoenix as the defending conference
champion um but you're still waiting on
chris paul
um
so i mean i do think that the west might
be a little wider open than than than we
thought about it this season in terms of
it being kind of a two-horse race
all righty hey bill thanks for stopping
by and educating educate nissa and and
making these two uh uh individuals in
the room here smile a lot when they're
talking about lakers
diminishments uh
they're getting a kick out of this
building wait bill real quick do you
think do you think a.d is coming back
this year and should lebron shut it down
um
i think it remains to be seen on both
those fronts i i think there's a
scenario that a.d doesn't come back but
i do think listen this is a guy who's
been injured a lot is sensitive to the
talk about being injured and sensitive
to talk about not being tough i think
you know he's going to want to get out
there unless the season is just
completely gone if they're still with
even within reach of the play-in i think
he'll want to come back uh lebron is a
little more complicated because there is
the personal pursuit right he's gonna
pass carl malone this season you know in
the next few weeks on the all-time
scoring list and to move to number two
um you know there is something to be
said for not just limping past kareem
abdul-jabbar's mark but kind of blowing
the doors off of it so i think that he
wants to get as many points under his
belt as he can but if you get to five or
six games left you're way out of the
play-in i could see lebron shutting it
down
right
appreciate that bill bill orem from the
athletic lakers beat rider thanks for
taking the time today bill it was a lot
of fun
thanks ryan i'll meet you at the mo club
all right i like it i like it
bill orm athletic beat writer for the
lakers hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here